relationship maybes kick-ass serpent
ladies and floating babies let's discuss
this premiere craziness on Sweetwater
secrets
[Music]
hey river babes on your south side
repping host Liana Galera and this is
your after show for the first episode of
Riverdale's third season
chapter 36 Labor Day we have so much to
discuss but I need to tell you that I'm
bringing you exclusive interviews from
KJ Appa Lilly Reinhart and Luke Perry
plus a very important relationship
answer from showrunner Roberto
aguirre-sacasa as always I'll be serving
up a vicious round of hisses and kisses
so start sending me your thoughts in the
comments below but first we need to
quickly recap the Premier's biggest
moments in the blue and gold breakdown
alright guys we're gonna keep this quick
so we can get to the scoop basically the
premier picks up three months after we
last saw our riverdale Ian's and they've
been spending all summer long in the
courthouse while Archie has been on
trial for murder after giving Archie one
last weekend of freedom the judge called
in the jury for a verdict but they
couldn't come to a unanimous decision so
rather than putting his family and
friends through these stress of yet
another trial
Archie decided to sentence himself and
take the plea deal I'll take two do
we have to discuss this but you and
everyone else through this again Your
Honor I accept the deal were you in a
way by Archie's choice
yeah me too so I asked KJ Alpha about it
and here's what he had to say oh my
goodness
Archie's going off to jail were you
surprised that he just blurted out that
he was gonna take that deal no I knew
that I that's kind of the nature of
Archie you know he he did that big - in
the Missouri for his friends and his
family and I think that was the only way
for him to do that but I'm I was stoked
when I heard about that being able to go
to president that was opening up such an
epic storyline
well at least KJ is happy about it even
if we're not over on the Serpent's side
of things jug had discovered that the
Ghoulies had dognapped hotdogs what the
heck who does that
honestly anyways he gathered up his top
serpents yes even Queen Betty and went
on a late-night rescue mission
thanks to Cheryl's awesome aim hot dog
was reunited with his family but
jugheads journey did not have a happy
ending before heading out to Archie's
trial Dilton doily had come to jugheads
trailer looking for his help about a
game called Griffins and gargoyles and
the new big dad of season 3 the car
talking but then Tilton wasn't in the
trailer when juggy got back so Jughead
decided to decipher Tilton's weird map
thing and followed him and found him
lying lifeless in the middle of fox
forest with weird carvings on his back
and guessed who was with him it's hot
dog dude ven where are the dogs yes the
guy who has been lurking around for
three seasons is back and let's hope
he's okay but if you thought that the
potential death of two boys would be the
craziest part of this premiere you guys
think again over in the Cooper household
Betty watched all summer long as her mom
sank deeper and deeper into Polly's
colty world of the farm but Betty had
her own summer secrets
turns out Betty was lying about seeing a
therapist and had been abusing her
prescription for adderall as a way to
hyper focus on helping Archie's trial
and avoid the fact that her dad murdered
a whole bunch of people last year I
can't do this right now
Blaine you girl in the final season of
the episode Betty watched as Paulie and
Alice and their weird farm II friends
held juniper and Dagwood over an open
fire and then they let go and then the
babies were floating they were floating
anyways in a state of shock
Betty started having a seizure and then
the episode ended what yeah I needed to
get to the bottom of this so here's what
Lily Reinhart and me choose a make had
to tell me about that shocking premiere
cliffhanger okay can we talk about
flying babies sure let's talk about
flying babies okay
when you read in that season 1 script
and then saw the episode you both have
seen it now the babies be floating what
is it loading I actually got chills when
I read it as I was happening I
immediately texted Roberto after I read
the first scripts and I say is there
magic in this show yeah and he said no
lady um yeah he said no there's not
and I was like okay so that means it
must have been a figment of her
imagination a hallucination a mix
between adderall and stress but yeah
it's definitely not supernatural which
was to me a relief because I was like
where where are we going we're already
going off the rails a little bit now
let's switch gears and focus on the
episodes most romantic moments in seven
seconds in heaven
first up let's talk Joni apparently our
to sultry serpents spent their summer
riding cross-country on the back of
Tony's motorcycle I wish we could have
had a little flashback glimpse of their
road trip romance like the other couples
got at the beginning of the episode but
at this point I'll take what we can get
and what we got was a new nickname TT
and a heartfelt confession from Cheryl
but no kiss did I miss something
that we were getting romance no yes okay
I didn't miss that sweet pea and Josie
are our newest Riverdale twosome and
even though miss McCoy seems to be
playing hard-to-get I'm still here for
it and it looks like it Kevin isn't
forgetting what he wants from Moose over
with a bug head Betty's new royal status
with the serpents has her all fired up
and truthfully I'm loving what I'm
seeing the serpent Queen is a warrior
queen and the way Jake had looked at his
warrior queen after that inspiring
speech was too perfect
but the best part was their fireside
bonding moment from now on were partners
in serpents in life all of it okay we
gave her his hat and basically said
they're gonna be together forever and I
can't
and while bug-head was exchanging
articles of clothing barn she was taking
theirs off I don't blame them I loved
that Veronica was so vocal about how
much she loves her Mane in this episode
but I do want to point out something to
you all who else remembers Veronica's
epic we our end game declaration during
her speech to hire him in the season 3
trailer I remember it now who else to
notice that it was cut from the episode
I did so I called up River doe
showrunner Roberto aguirre-sacasa to get
the answers on this and when I asked him
what happened to the end game line he
said quote wait was it removed from the
episode and then when I explained that
it was indeed left out of the episode he
said quote oh my gosh
well I think it could have been two
things one is Veronica's passion is
clear
two is that it could be it's a sentiment
that we echo and subsequent episodes so
it could be those two
reasons but it's certainly not because
var chi is not endgame oh okay
keep breathing var tree fans it's
nothing to panic about but let's move on
to something that's never gonna get cut
out of my episodes this is and this is
alright
hisses that one's going straight to the
Ghoulies for just existing seriously who
steals a dog awful people that's who
pisses to the return of penny Peabody
and to the fact that she wanted to
revoke Jughead serpent jacket just cuz
they're no longer running the Southside
seriously penny don't you know that
alliterations is the secret to any great
franchise hisses to the fact that it
seems like Luce might be stringing Kevin
along and to those six people on the
jury for not being able to see that
Archie was clearly innocent but also his
sister Archie for taking that deal you
did not need to do that read I'm diggin
that bowtie though this is two floating
babies to Polly for pushing her coltie
farm crap down everyone's throat and
Alice for trying to burn Betty's Diaries
get the hell away from your mother
because she had been body-snatched but
also Polly even though I'm real pissed
at you right now I will take a moment to
tell you that your new haircut is super
cute hashtag mom life business to hire
um for destroying the life of an
innocent teenager despite the fact that
his daughter begged him to stop once
again get a hobby
hyrum huh but on the flip side my first
kiss of the season is going straight to
Fred for a punching high room in his
smug face and here's some
behind-the-scenes secrets straight from
Luke Perry about filming that moment
we're gonna talk about a little spoiler
and episode one oh boy Luke we see in
the first episode that Fred loses his
temper with Hyrum and socks him right in
the face what was that like for you to
punch your real-life friend mr. Martin's
family yeah mr. Marcus well it took more
than one take that yeah we had we had to
do a few and it was good it you know
mark he's always ready to go for stuff
like that yeah
he loves it yeah if they hadn't called
cut he'd have been swinging right back
yeah yeah it was good kisses to the hot
dad's of Riverdale for reuniting and
Hermione for finally letting us in on
her wicked little secret we'll get you
out of that marriage girl kisses to
Cheryl's kick-ass season 3 intro with
that red leather jacket and her Cherry's
out-and-proud
I screamed and kisses to Shoni for
reigning over the pool party like the
Queen's that they are kisses to bar
cheese fireside romance and that
adorable bug-head beanie moment kisses
to the new reigning serpents to Betty
for refusing to leave her Kings side and
to this teeny tiny line that brought me
a ridiculous amount of joy not yet to
cousin and kisses to the fact that I'm
no longer gonna be watching arrow
because I've got my own bow wielding
vigilante to root for also kisses to the
way that Jughead yelled I don't know
about you but ever you watch that part
like 12 times and there you have it that
does it for our very first after-show
episode of Sweetwater secrets in season
3 and I'll see you on Wednesday for our
next preview episode for chapter 37
Fortune and men's eyes for now you guys
know what to do hit the comments with
your hisses and kisses of this episode
are you upset that Veronica's end game
moment was cut from the premiere which
couple made you swoon the most and what
do you think of flying babies and The
Gargoyle King tell me thanks for
watching Sweetwater secrets and I'll see
you next time river babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]